he'll face sam coonrod making his second
start in his major league career his
first one went his last timeout as the
phillies continue to do these bullpen
games
and again they may do it the rest of the
season we shall see one ball two strikes
swing in the miss 99 on the inner half
and an easy one two three first inning
for sam coonrod he sets the rockies down
in order we're out to the bottom of the
first here in philadelphia hermann needs
a good start it's so unusual to say that
but his last five starts not good by his
standards and uh the previous nine a 194
but his last five
a triple seven
that's on the outside corner he dropped
the curve ball in and herrera
is a strikeout victim
price is wearing the same spikes that he
had on cleats that he had on the other
day trying to raise awareness for
childhood cancer awareness month i like
those
there's a base hit it to center field so
off the end of the bat
he's a board
it's a two out single another 02 and
that's where he wanted to locate the
curveball he gets the strike out of
robuto
harper left it first two strikeouts for
heremon in any number one no score belly
falters the new pitcher for the fills
locate that fastball
swing and a miss he located it there
second strikeout for phil's pitching and
one out here in the second excellent
fastball up in the zone with some good
life right there and that's kind of his
signature pitch
does create a lot of life with that with
that release way out in front hides the
ball very well
back to back walks pushes diaz to second
sam hillary who you just saw on deck
will come up
this ball is pulled through the hole and
around third coming home is elias diaz
throw from harper is not gonna get him
and the rockies take a one-nothing lead
on hilliard's base hit here's dazza
and this ball is lace to left center
field that'll score welker easily sam
hilliard on his way to third dazza into
second safely ball gets away for a
moment
hilliard took a couple of steps down the
line and stopped
well done jonathan dazza and it's two to
nothing colorado well that'll be it for
belly fault of the phillies back to the
bullpen campedrosians coming in
marcus will face cam bedrosian
and this is softly lined to right this
will drop hilliard obviously scores
dazza moves up 90 feet and that's why we
told you that there's no way they were
going to let falter face herman that is
his seventh ribby of the year
and
that is ball four third walk six
straight have reached as the bases are
loaded for trevor story
popped up
shallow right field
field flywheel could be called
and it is called late
swag and a miss ran the high fastball up
nine men came to the plate of the inning
for the rockies they scored three runs
2-2
good curveball that's such a lethal
combination so is his slider his
curveball and his curveball
against right-handed hitters produces a
strikeout 64 of the time
in a two-strike situation
as you see another slider
dawson center field
good job by herman
to miss
that's a good split second strikeout of
mcmahon tonight
one of all two strikes
popped up behind home plate off to the
right jt again nearly the same spot
reaches toward the net makes the grab
and the side is retired
he had two foul pops to the catcher in
that inning
second one was more impressive than the
first
in some ways it shows his athleticism
guinness and dazza
a little chopper out in front of the
mound moore's got it his throw was into
the runner dazza is safe
thought about it instead he'll go to
segura and in scoring position with two
outs is dazza as charlie blackman will
come up
this is line the left base hit daz
around third he'll come home
mccutcheon
returns it to the infield charlie
blackman two out knock four nothing
colorado
and a swing and a miss on a slider
that is uh strikeout number four on the
evening one out andrew mccutchen coming
up
breaking ball and this is lifted to
shallow center field dazzle can he get
there yep good closing speed very good
closing speed you could tell he kept the
glove tucked
eyes on the ball i also really really
really like him sliding feet first right
here because it allows you to get your
palm and thumb underneath the baseball
which is paramount otherwise the ball
can come out
trevor oh for three to nine he's reached
in 13 straight ball
this games lifted to deep left field and
this is going to get on out of here
mccutcheon kind of gave it a cursory
look and trevor with his 20th of the
year makes it 5-0 colorado and folks he
was a little fooled he was out on his
front side and he one-handed that about
380.
pays to be strong
cj kroon
oh this ball club take a good look you
won't see this for long
crone
launches what left his 27th of the year
as crone and story go back to back
six nothing colorado they did it last
night tonight's the night time that
they've gone back to back this year
which ties them for the lead with the
san francisco giants
that ball was crushed
that ball was hammered
going two
round ball out to second base diving
stops agora from a knee to second for
one over the first not in time
what a play by segora
they may review that one
at first base i think they thought they
got him this is a great play look at
this
it's a tremendous play
here we go and he is out
gotta applaud that defense segora
throwing some leather around
in the night he's walked two of the
first three
cj crone
that ball is ripped through the left
side a base hit blackman around third
he's heading home
the throw from mccutcheon's cut off and
the rockies lead at seven nothing
and now they're loaded up for elias
ridge this ball's hit a long way did he
get all of it yeah yeah
grand slam
elias diaz
it's been the year of the slam for the
rockies
and for elias home run number 17.
you dropped the hammer on that one drew
ah
it's nicely done
dd gregorius will
lead things off
that ball is going to be out of the
ballpark for dede gregorius
just at the foot actually it may have
hit the auxiliary scoreboard
his 11th home run of the year the
phillies are finally on the board
it's an 11-1 ball game
well that's nice to get something i mean
no one wants to get blank especially
after tonight like last night followed
up by the way this game has came out to
come out today but putting something on
the board feels a little better than
just getting blanks
herrera is going to be the batter
[Music]
topper in front of the plate bowdoin off
the mound has it and he throws it wide
of cj crone down the right field line
oh double to second base
and bowdoin is uh
yelling at himself
[Applause]
and inside ball four so the inning stays
alive
and it brings harper up he's one for
three tonight
to the pitcher
bouncer over toward the vacant hole and
it's into center field to base it o
double score it'll be an rbi single for
harper
it's 11-2
and ball four that'll load the bases up
brad miller's due up
in the air to center field this will do
it
dazzle makes the catch and that's the
ball game the rockies have won the first
two in philadelphia just third time this
year they've won back to back on the
road and they win it going away 11-2
you